levels of the levels is good see
starting waiting for the joint
alright good welcome to the OBS forest
Lord gaben that episode number 120 and
it's another glorious Sunday we're back
at the round table and the Lord's Day
and we've got ESA daxing III info
Microsoft signing a ninja destiny -
shadow keep delayed Colin Moriarty
versus pax and EA Sheamus which to
discuss so we go get right into it so
let's introduce the four horsemen of
gaming those original Lords of the realm
here at the round table my calls were
the Col most my brother from another
mother the difficult game Conqueror and
the heart of the young wolf mommy
Lord addict are you doing sir doing
pretty god I do want to mention all the
other people that are using discord and
not Google hangout so that's unnecessary
you could still use Google Hangouts like
literally everyone I see you trying
discs or like I think this cord looks
ugly unless you do a custom template
when your shout out to infernal Howie
hey in your final no we will sit down
with you chop it up you go get all that
then I'm forcing it I'm putting it out
the energy is out there we have started
we are on our journey
[Music]
apologies to the realm we had a non
premium stream go up for testing
purposes at my man Atticus helping me
get through my frustration of learning
he was teaching me there's a lot of
frustration
I'm pretty sure they hurt really was it
was it iron Lords after dark
see the tags he was using no one else I
was sitting here on pins and needles
hope stuff go come opt-out state up to
like 6:00 in the morning it's a learning
process so bear with us lords but like
Kay said I eventually will be looking to
elevate the situation so just bear with
us we're learning and of course we have
our most technical gaming Lord the solo
gamer who lives for the single player
selfish experience and also the sastra
Damas mr. Flom profile luminary and
location of the iron bank mommy Lord
sovereign how you doing sir what up what
up what's going on I'm till and I both
eyes this week I'm back no more fury
good chillin I've been uh since I got my
eyes back yes I'm excellent went to the
eye doctor yesterday I needed to get
some new contacts and new glasses and he
was like the cornea is good good to go
scratchy shout out the Lord Jack move he
had like a similar thing they gave him
glasses I made him look like more feet
the dark around I just literally like
Morpheus yeah so you know that we like
part of my job now is sort of dealing
with wit with different types of
departments and specific things that
they get rid of particularly where you
used to work can be right so yeah in
transporting some some not cool stuff
right something from the bag broke
Oh ruin my face oh my god
and for my face and the thing about it
is that stuff I'm actually allergic to
as it is so if it touches my skin I so
it went right in my eye and my eye look
like a tomato right after happens so
then I had to like go and I was she had
to go do that I was gotta go do the eye
wash okay then after that actually I
took a claritin-d and that cleaned up
that cleared it up completely so I
thought I was good and they were like no
go check it out and lo and behold had
the scratched cornea so no antibiotics
and all that stuff it's all taken care
of so thanks then I take the time that I
worked under the UV light without the
shielding oh no this just seems like a
really bad all right so I'm working in
the UV light and I didn't know that
because they tell you the procedure
right so I just jumped inside the room
really it was knocking out to stuff and
I'm working in the UV light but I didn't
turn the shielding on there's a
shielding that blocks your eyes yeah I'm
having a home for race so I'm thinking
this obvious trust me when they tell you
to block your eyes it is not BS all
right so I go home I'm taking a train
this is way back in the days I'm taking
a train and sitting in the trees like
getting tunnel vision right
my vision is zooming in right so I'm
walking home as I'm walking home at this
getting smaller so as I come up the
steps I get in the house um and I laid
out on the bed
I'm completely blind at this point I'm
panicking in the house I'm by myself
I don't have a cellphone because that
was well I was a force cellphone mommy I
always had a cellphone
no matter fact I did have a cell Bowman
but I couldn't see the numbers oh wow
right so I'm just I'm just laying and
hoping somebody calls me I fall asleep I
had to work that Sunday this happened
that Saturday had to work that Sunday
chairs was it at the animals yeah it
says good no boy right so he calls me in
the morning he like yo my man you late
you want me to clock you in haha shout
out to people stealing timers s
fingerprints that you own dick now so
alright I get up and I'm like man my
eyes is mad crusty and if my face feels
heavy like like like I was in a fight I
go look in the mirror both of my eyes is
the size of his microphone like each eye
like in a shut and I can barely see
don't know but I could see but my eyes
is [ __ ] filled with like you know like
mad mucus and fluid my I was so
appreciative that I was able to see
after that no I couldn't sue nobody
because it was all on me
yeah but I was scared to death yeah yeah
it's that flash burn and if you don't if
you don't know any better you don't get
specifically trained in that is it it'll
you'll go in and not even know it what
you have to do so now I'm David and this
is back in the day now they make sure
that they train you like however many
times they have to make sure that you
got it yeah
they have to do it because there have
been people who have left the job and
and and gotten a decent amount of money
from them because they weren't properly
trying well actually yes I really
whoa I was playing more blood-stained
man I mean that game is fantastic it
really is and I know that's what Rose is
back in the bush and I wouldn't even I
wouldn't mind if it was a solid 30 that
wouldn't bother me it's just everything
else that goes along with it like it was
poor it seems like it's poorly optimized
and they've been talking about doing
updates that have not come to pass yet
so I don't know where these updates have
it said they coming so we'll see but I'm
done with that version but what else did
I play I haven't gone back to -
Youngblood like I'll go back to it
eventually
so right um I saw another person that I
respect his game I'm not saying I don't
spike a game um but I saw his video on
it I didn't know it was getting a loan
Metacritic score even though I don't
care about that right there one egg one
positive thing about it right and I've
heard just nothing but pure negativity
tore towards it and I'm like man these
people are so resistant to change don't
change my mind the wheels on my car
don't change it right I'm like yo really
this is a side-story brother this is
where they supposed to be able to get
that ability to flex their who to show
you do you like it this way and I fully
agree with that I agree with that take
you take the side stories to experiment
go crazy I don't know that this works if
you put it in the main line are
Wolfenstein stuff so that that's to me I
think just leave it there yeah I hope is
that play I'll play more Fire Emblem so
i adding oh that's a fire it's an attic
for blazing and beating the game i don't
you know what's funny you know cuz you
have a brush out the console right yeah
sonic is like my crazy like my little
bro
right so the funny thing is i get
what you go through the carboxyl Oh
blazes just yeah I can't even come out
and you like yeah we both got it just
the static term and you speak them two
days later he's like yeah I'm at the end
they couldn't soon games it is it makes
you disgusted like we will play the game
oh boy yes so mad he could not have
spoiled you on it but you get so pissed
on articles boy I totally told him the
twist of the robots who need to go to
spoiler etiquette school those our pride
to tell people like certain certain
people have a real knack for stuff and I
sat then I watch a dick play and I was
like this dude is really out of control
like when we was playing a sin game
remember that same game at it we're an
open standard sacrifice redemption it
wasn't you the only person that ended it
right there
mmm yeah I actually I was on like the
last boss when I got goosebumps just
saying it right there what's funny is
I'm the only person I know cuz there's a
there's a boss in that game that has two
forms but if you're good enough you
could kill her before she goes into her
second floor I'm the only person I ever
know that's done that that's the only
thing I've never been one to really like
watching like we're going into the into
the talk about the mixer in the
ninja-like watchings but I will watch
attic and I will watch car Basu yeah
it's something about this you know in
those particular types of games like the
platformers in you gotta watch kids
smooth to all this challenge yeah
opposite end of the spectrum
no eat your food while you watching his
stream because go up
actually entertaining on shrooms yes you
could solve for dealing with a brother a
lot yeah he is a savant assistant that
last mission is rough no he hasn't
mentioned that he has it cuz I know he
was trying to hold off and actually I
was gonna hold off on it at first until
I started hearing these reviews and I
might hold up I need to be part of the
zeitgeist I gotta pick it up so I
actually don't know if he's picked it up
maybe he has um and then the last thing
I have to say that I played and add to
give a big shout out to 2004 yes I had
to go out to get that Dhoom 3 I and I
had to do it on the switch is a mister
absolute no it's actually it's 1080p 60
frames per second no is it down here we
are here from another place I had this
huh me one tell me why you had to bump
your head against the road remember
listen I just so happy but in 2004 that
was the first time I ever bought a
gaming PC like really I spent nearly
twenty five hundred dollars on a gaming
PC for two games make me three games far
cry right in the original Far Cry that
we still can run right exactly half-life
2 and doom 3 doom 3 was that first
moment was it it was that first game
that was like okay can you run Crysis
can you run it was one of those game it
was it was the pinnacle the absolute
integral of graphical fidelity it was
just amazing and you needed a monster
machine to do that I remember I got that
a salon 64 that AMD and then I had the
the whatchamacallit the up the Nvidia
like the GTE the GT 6800 something like
that crazy money on this so just see
that game running at optimal settings on
this time I needed to do it I need it's
crazy it's been 15
oh this morning one is on the X and one
is on the pros native 4k it is and guess
what my dumbass got it there too is one
of those games that it marked the point
in time it really did shout-out to Rick
little recipes to the home in the hablo
ex I went to his house and he was I had
gave up on gaming pcs I went to his
house into the new boomers out I was
like so kids and I got his house and he
turned it on with the lights off and
when you get all four you come in that
first room and densifier the next day I
went out and got made gaming PC day
because I got off there this one the
reason food oh and all I remember rocks
and all that me and Brian was on some
crazy new the lord of combat sports king
of the statutes who demands nothing less
than that premium and experience it is
the leader of the fraud alert movement
who beloved Lord gay guy you do exert
listen let me tell you under the
circumstances I'm gonna do fantastic I
don't care no matter what you're not
gonna stop the globe this is what let me
tell you what and what I'm saying with
this ever since this bathroom has had
that over Florida and had that issue
back there with that bathroom um I had I
want everybody to go out hit Empire
today those are people that did the
floor the laminate flooring shout out to
them for this continuing the the
laminate flooring that I have here you
see that shout out for them for
discontinued a year later after I got it
so now now I have to have in my laundry
area because the laundry you like I can
see the washing machine and dryer over
there I have to have a separate
different tiling for the laundry area or
I had to do this whole floor
ompletely than a new arm laminate now
while he hid a working they decide that
we gonna break a statue we go we don't
break a statue and care to act like the
statute on hotdogs the Shelf by itself
Disney I don't know who you are but yeah
I just have to say that I concur sir
I can't wait for when y'all have to
swipe that card on the side of your
please be there for free this one is
like a watch figure it out all in your
wallet so all those two dollars you send
in every week you should have saved it
all right so so after I get on the phone
or whatever do try to boss up or
whatever I really I had I was taken
aback because I said this is gonna be a
situation y'all probably wouldn't gotten
on the podcast date right because I was
definitely gonna go to jail but um
shout-out to being older and wiser and I
decided that's not the wave all right
during this week I hop out I'm at work I
hop out and I'm going to one of my
locations and a brother is walking up
the block and he's walking up the block
and I got out on the you're 18 was no
baby I didn't forget how tall I am a
house shopping I am I tend to forget
this right so I'm approaching him like
he's a regular size that we regular size
people together he's a swole smallish
kind of dude now as I'm hopping out go
supreme hops out the side of the truck
and when he hops out the side of the
truck go she's mad short so you just see
a figure moving on the side of the car I
look Legionnaire with his eyes now at
this time
me and go she's wearing matching iron
Lords shirt oh so he think is the goes
in the fear that was in this man's eyes
so I'm talking to and I'm like why is he
actively making his way to the hotel he
didn't have any security with him he was
out there with the bellhop the bellhop
probably walked into the store wherever
they get the good food or whatever he's
walking back with it and I'm like yeah
he's like yeah you know and the jewelry
on or nothing and you making his way to
the hotel in a click in my head I'm like
oh it was the get down shout out to
Jason Elliott with the file out of super
chat King David I know this is gaming
please speak of fury fighting - dude
none of us has ever listen I'm gonna
give you that right now just as you can
see I was just gonna be going - I
understood now why um my Brona was here
he was in New York
shoutout to Brooklyn Brooklyn's in the
house um New York was rockin this
weekend with a series of fights now I go
into these fights because I didn't feel
that they were something like there was
a big fight these are fighter fighters
you know like sovereign will probably
watch it
cocky will probably watch it you know
uh-oh Queen OH
we'll watch it you know real fight hits
so um you had a cast nakki versus areola
as the main a fight and that was a
knockout drag them out both out of shape
looking heavyweight but I think it's a
new wave going off for the don't don't
do no sit-ups no add work with these
voices in the mix no like they they are
actually thorn they set the record for
the most punches thrown in a heavyweight
fight so if you want to go check out an
interest and fight entertain if I go
watch casablanca versus
areola alright oh in the um sub main
event you have pascal versus brown now
Pascal is trained Jean Pascal is delight
heavy weight he used to be like every
champion he's trained by Roy Jones
always everyone right now Roy his idol
when he lost before he had to come back
with his idol he wanted to do a farewell
tour whatever with his idol and you saw
what Roy taught that boy in that fight
he hit Brown with punches I mean
straight up sock him in the mouth
punches he hit the ground so hard one
shot he just put him on his butt and
brown just look like and it came from
Roy if you are a fan of Roy being passed
out Dean gene passed je8 and Pascal TAS
C al so he went on to beat Brown which
Brown was the favorite in that fight
every fight last night was fantastic
all right and then you had a Stevenson
versus Ola butch it the hell out of your
name because you were supposed to win
but you beat the brakes off a Stevenson
shoutout to you for doing your job I do
appreciate great fights and live dogs
coming to the fight
Covington Oh you know when your phone is
blowing up so my phone is blowing up
like yo-yo tournament you'll see right
now turn the horsey right now I turn to
you'll see why is he coming out like
Kurt Angle was the best
entertaining ring walk I've seen from
USC ever and I'm watching you guys I
think he's doing a good thing when he
playing his heel crap I like what's
going on with him
the fight was super entertaining they
were this dude I don't care if you like
them or hate him he is mus why he's must
watch yeah did you see the post
first of all he disrespect Matthew he
wanted he said cuz you know man who was
that guy instead of on the car accident
joint right so he got to the call you
disrespect Matt he's like yeah cuz you
know the Kolby trainings if you wave you
want to track you won't get run over
don't be a Matthew was get by the tress
and yo I told ya dude accident right so
this is not dead dude he's like come on
rules
what are you calling to Marty cuz they
keep using that narrative that his real
name is Marty like he be fright like
Africa so they say oh yeah Marty fake
newsmen so he like yeah you faking
injuries you faking injuries you don't
want to see me you out here you can
fight right now but we know what you're
trying to do you hold on bail so they
come on get up on the joint and he's
like yo what's up so it starts popping
off at the on the interview joint and
like what you called was like yeah cuz
we know you from this that he said y'all
forget about December
what about Kumar's like what about right
now is just to break up up yo it was
late I have a UFC fit I mean I mean I
mean the WWE it's pure yeah
so that was definitely Dana shoutout to
cyborg yeah no Medina fan and look we
all have our issues with sidewalk in the
past or whatever but the way he's
handling this situation that she got
released like not feeling it and then
what I don't like is that like when a
fighter stock cuz obviously she got
blazed by Amanda right so now he's
running with this narrative like oh
she's scared and you know this standard
does she wants easy fights in our lab
but it's like when you call somebody you
call a chicken man and you personally
disparaging
I could okay I saw the joint no no most
of it was taking on the context but at
the same point in time you being the CEO
you being a boss you don't do that to me
but it's not his brand
remember we tall ready talked that if he
didn't build you up he don't care about
you
and she ain't with her already
established brand and her brand was very
strong he he takes pride and joy in
breaking you down as you bred and born
in the UFC he takes pride and joy and
tearing you up and destroying your
casting you to decide what it's time for
you to go on because he said that he
will not uh try to match any offer that
she has got Bellator anything else
so her leverage going into negotiations
is zero
oh okay all right
so remember when I made that mistake at
Microsoft it was $14 in 95 they gave me
back my money so they admitted guilt um
yo Dragon Ball Z fighters is $14.95 and
I downloaded it I paid my $14.95 shout
out to young Chris that game is the best
looking game of our generation I'm
telling you right now if it looks
completely like the cartoon yes that
destiny getting my opulence on and of
course we have the Lord the cooperative
experience and gaming engine himself the
shinobi lore Cognito spread and everyone
is in the realm of the ILP and I'm
telling you what you want to hear but
what you need to hear destiny sources of
Heroes has been for me the grind is in
full full effect been getting that going
on try to get my flag gear before a
shadow key
Leo I am I'm on a switch got to touch a
little bit of man nor yeah access to see
what time it is what's going on - I'm a
fraud man I only play matter when my
team is good oh yeah let's see you've
got prospects and daddies looking like
they bite beefs up this year shall I let
me see what Jimmy G and crew gonna do
you don't say but yeah man that's pretty
much that
I'll see watch UFC we talked about that
old joint bought off yeah let's get into
address a Jason Elliott self-id our
super Chad um Jason you know that no one
knows who furious fighting he signed
that contract with ESPN and he's trying
to milk it for as long as he can go so
um his stock can only go up if he keeps
winning so it doesn't matter with a lot
of these guys that can do no wrong like
triple G and other guys I will go into
that on another time with you know
racism and box and stuff like that but
he's allowed to fight these tomato cans
and pad his record going forward you
know and I know his crap I would not be
no covering anything of that type of
fight though you know forward if these
heavyweights in these champions want any
type of recognition from my area they
will have to step up to the plate you
know shout-out today on say while the
fighting King Kong cotys again ii have
yes yeah he dropped him but he had him
on the ropes
Deonte has never been down but he was
almost out of it oh but did he got he
got a big way out of it really matching
that dude yeah
he's one of those champions that even if
he won he didn't win how he wanted to
win and he goes work that backward we
have some bills to pay is that time of
the month once again to say thank you to
our loyal patrons so let's get this get
that going let's do it we'll start off
with first off Lord meds thank you so
much brother
and of course forever patron Lord Cory
Lydick aka Lord whiskey and Lord slow-mo
backslap almost a batoning King Emma
Emma and sat out - Lord
HB 33 thank you for the or brother so of
course I'll fellow you - brethren
Nintendo Direct is going on man I like
Malaika and of course rate the Emperor
rage big shout out then - Lord QX
masters no I'm just I'm not really I
immediately segue into a government cuz
that's the only name I have Vincent Gary
diri in it he's a new patron so thank
you so much
no doubt followed by another new patron
Lord
Zorro and of course followed by Fastback
67-68 thank you sir oh so he's followed
by Lord stitch 6660 now I lover of
switch Tom what I was thinking about all
the patreon that are you know and they
birthday mom it was shout-out to him
especially if it's close to their dead
dick you gotta really burn for among
Jews were given us some special we're
gonna need that info because I don't
that info is not
all right just follow my lord and of
course followed by friends around family
to the realm Lord Gaming Forte be a
petiole patient should receive an ease
by King hashtags gonna be so sad when
you go to turn on your Playstation five
you realize there's no back bad ability
[Music]
right hello and for tales followed by a
friend and get well soon brother hope
you're feeling better my friend Lord
undead yo shout out the onion first of
all yo all y'all hit up on day three xvr
he's in the hospital right now he's
going through it please send him some
love snow wishes that stuff that's the
homie right there we wish him nothing
but the best in health so you're out
right if you got a son I hope you
listening and hopefully least you can
smile because we definite thing about
you we want you all right in the round
socially damn
no doubt no doubt so Lord undead is
fired by Lord linchpin shoutout to you
followed by the Lord of X cloud in front
of the round Lord bill still well no I
hope I hope your leg is a better yeah
and his web shoutout to the room he said
he said the do got out there that day
and tried to show his slaps business I
was dead dead boy I was dead swelling
and all that stuff is going down man but
definitely wish you the best
alright so followed by patron number one
Lord Michael Lugo aka monkey punch
to married out out bottled by Lord Sammy
Prescott followed by once again I
believe yes a brand new patron Lord
night music I remember seeing in the
chat last week good-looking thank you
for joining the patreon and of course
family to the man of the every single
color way ever created alright look
daddy followed by Lord Tao a kthe no
doubt no doubt
followed by Lord Johanns ovj gasps
every month every month man yo guess who
followed me on on Twitter Christopher
Hart all loved it and of course last but
not least Lord death singer from across
the pond thank you sir for all the
support from the very beginning no doubt
so let's get into those payments did not
go through you know what all right so
the winner of our $10 gift card giveaway
is AHA new patron your Lord Vincent
Deary everybody gets a freebie you know
at least a month or two of no palm
greasing the cry do it I'll get you that
information and all right let's get into
this $20 gift card giveaway and the
winner of our $20 gift card giveaway a
oh my god hell has frozen over what Lord
slow-mo every life is rigged
Yosi well drop the bag off the correct
way to stoop with your name excited what
happens good things happen Dragon Ball Z
fighters we see his big I work too hard
[Laughter]
alright last but not least our teespring
giveaway Oh apologies to the two
previous teespring and winners as you
well know teespring
only ships and waves so your orders are
sitting there and I'm waiting for
shipping information that has not come
to me yet soon as I have it you'll have
it alright so the winner of our
teespring giveaway is Lord Sammy
Prescott down for sale not out in
congratulations to all our patrons to
all our new patrons thank you for the
support thank you for showing up we
really appreciate it
we're working on on making a difference
to this thing like I said it's very
weird and I'm never around so whatever
what is my first salute this area Wow
yeah me no doubt no doubt so that's a
good thing so once again man we
appreciate all the love you guys have
been showing us is really no no I did
not win so this is my first one I'd like
to see more more rotting messages in the
exactly so that's what we got saw we are
good at realm yester Bank another
monthly iron bank fantastic let's get
into the poll results and get to show
popping so last week's poll results are
in and the people have spoken
to the question but the
critically-acclaimed release of fire
emblem and switches scheduled switch
light and software lineup for the rest
of the year do you think this will
translate to Nintendo winning MPD
hardware sales for the remainder of 2019
the winner at 66% of the latest
three-way il poll by o people was the
switch trade it's full steam ahead cut
out the You Tube convenient fluence --is
[Laughter]
what's the petit Lords I don't care
joy Conger if they terrible online
service automatically keeps them in the
bushes group that's me at last place
with only 11 percent of the vote was the
cog stop getting gas PlayStation 4 and
Xbox will win at least one Hardware
month in 2019 group shout out to all the
lords who participated in last week's
poll Lord it is what it is yes look I
don't I don't I don't talk about Swift
propaganda so you know reading the
leaflets that they hand them out no I'm
not on the I'm not on the red kool-aid
okay like I I don't drink the kool-aid
because more Cognito has the gun to my
face and tells you to drink cool coming
in hot
we were going to do our normal order but
some things have transpired some
breaking breaking breaking news so we
gonna get right into it man e s a mp3
organizational leaks data on the two
thousand journalists and analysts so
pretty much if you apply for a press
press pass you know you have to provide
your information and that information
for the most part was always been secure
but as of a couple days ago
there was a list that was pretty much
accessible to anyone that had press
contact information phone numbers home
addresses the entire likes and I want a
shout out I believe her name is Sophia
Noor wits and she was one of the first
to breakthrough the attention on of
everybody but um from my understanding
she went and contacted the ESA and
contacted our very own home law as far
as to what steps to do before breaching
the story to the public and yeah this is
pretty hot they've since then the ESA
has made a reaction they are calling it
they were made aware of a website
vulnerability that led to the contact
list of registered journalists attendant
III being made public
once notify we immediately took steps to
protect the data and shut down the site
which is no longer available so uh
there's some point of contention here
you know a lot of people are saying this
is not evolved early some people are
saying that this was an Excel
spreadsheet easily accessible by just a
link that said helpful links with all
this information so uh yeah I guess I
guess at the end it was a helpful way
attic man I mean with all this has come
out what's your stance on it you know
what do you think the impact is and um
just a safety for everyone any three I
think you know people keep saying stuff
like oh it's only happened one time
something to this degree it only needs
to happen one time it'll be this much of
a big deal at the end of the day I think
III might be a rat well I think this is
gonna be a very big check because we're
not time in we're not talking about you
know people that have no influence in
the community we're not talking about
we're talking about you like people have
Jason Schreyer address like this you
don't have any weirdos out there should
not have Jason Schreyer za-- dress
like and we're not even I mean we're
talking about uh you know a bunch of in
flu
that probably have stalkers that follow
them on their on their on their streams
they might have their address like it's
it's it's it's more it's I feel like
people are underselling this more than
it's it's way more of an issue that
people are acting the other thing is I
think that we got to talk about is that
I've been seeing reports on that glad
you brought up that name home shelter
Jason but you know obviously reports
that people are blaming Sofia and
they're saying that um if she isn't yeah
message it and it wouldn't have been as
big as it was and listen just for the
record you know I'm saying mom I believe
Sophia's she she wrote for calamari
already and those guys at one point or
whatever so you know listen there's
always history with people's views and
stuff like that but you know at the end
of the day you know some journalists or
some people have taken exception to the
fact that she put the story out so she's
come since then coming to out with her
own videos and saying that she took the
necessary steps to do everything
possible to not you know to make ESA
aware first before going public so well
it's like she said in that video she
sent ESA a message immediately she tried
to call them immediately because she's
not a bigger youtuber big outlet they
didn't they didn't even open up the
message I mean us at Iron Horse Park
because we sent emails people probably
never ever open so it's like are we
gonna blame the person who just
discovered it then all right now it
emails at it look man all I know is
sometimes stuff happens it is what it is
but you know are we gonna blame the
person that discovered it and tried
their hardest to get it you know she
contacted people she trusted on that
list that you know could get the point
across but at the end of the day it's
like what are we gonna blame the person
to discover or the people who had the
breach in their system like I don't
understand what we blame in like we
blaming the victims victim like it makes
no sense
doesn't mean it feels like it there's
just hate involved that she's the one
that that broke the story and take the
fall
yeah exactly and it doesn't make any
sense to me I'm be honest I got this
bothers me on a bunch of different
levels first what kills me about it in
regards to how she's being treated is
that
it it feels like they're scapegoating
her because again they didn't nobody
else broke this story and what kills me
about what I've seen recently a I try
not to get on that bandwagon where
everybody hating games media whatever
cuz I you know I grew up listening to
games media this is how this is how
conversations that we're having today
started these guys I whatever the
politics of different outlets all
whatever I don't care about that but it
does feel like there is this there is
this overwhelming sort of sense trying
to suppress individual voices that that
outlets don't necessarily always address
maybe individual people at outlets
address on their own personal Twitter
account or whatever the case may be but
outlets in general as an entire entity
don't address the stuff the way it
should and that bothers me now this
stuff when it comes to the leak yeah
this is big because you can't try to get
away with the fact that it's it's it's a
security some sort of some sort of
breach or whatever when there is a link
to it on your page there is a heading
with a link to it you did this for
whatever reason how do you try to get
around this like how do you try to not
accept full responsibility for what you
did and why you did it
shout out the hole cuz Hogue broke it
down oh really in detail and basically
he's saying it this was on them to
handle from the very beginning when they
collected your information to ensure in
no way shape or form could this happen
so why and then he went into the details
about what they can share what they
can't share and in fact of the matter is
that the details the fine print isn't
very detailed the fine print is very
broad in order to allow them to not
accept fault for certain things right mm
man this this is just painful I know cog
you you had mentioned that you you might
have been
I'm a pilot I'm very concerned but we'll
get it to my boy oh I did it sucks all
the way around and I mean I I don't know
that if it's gonna affect III as a whole
I don't know if it changes the course of
what's happening with III and and what
it becomes but it's definitely gonna be
a sticking point moving forward and if
you know and it's enough big journalists
get behind you know attacking this and
making sure that they them held
responsible for this before passed okay
um what about listen we all know III I
don't say long to decline but it's not
as strong a show as it used to be right
so now we couple this leaked information
right now how do you think this affects
maybe going forward for 2020 like we
know people that was like yo we want to
go now granted those are mostly gonna be
gamer passes and stuff like that right
but you know how do you think this
affects media moving forward I mean this
is it's gonna depend on the fallout if
you start seeing you know you know big
journalists from from from bigger
outlets start saying listen man like
something somebody's knocking on my door
somebody's like you know I'm getting
crank calls I'm getting like my personal
safety and my personal space is being
invaded as a result of my information
being out there the more of that stuff
you start to hear the bigger the
pushback is gonna be so how it's gonna
depend on how serious it gets how many
crazies get a hold of this and decide to
do stupid things with it um and and it's
gonna depend on how the ESA addresses it
and they need to stop trying to push it
off to the side and accept that this
happened you know they're gonna it's
gonna be a scapegoat there's gonna be a
fall guy they're gonna find some way to
explain why that where that was even
there and why this happened whatever
they may be they still have to accept
end user
you know culpability for whatever
happens with this stuff they have to
regardless how they word it or how they
want to flip it or whatever they have to
address it directly right
fair enough Lord King
where are you act with the ESA III
daxing info alright um since when we
destroyed the messenger not the message
you know at what point in time do we get
to condemn the whistleblower for blowing
the whistle Oh some people have said
that she actually got some form of
following or whatever after that and she
was trying to be reputable she showed
you she's I think in the past been maybe
on the side of gamergate or something
yeah and you know I don't know what her
views is but obviously you know she's in
alignment with Collin and you know we
don't do politics on the Lord's but you
know I'm saying you know from my
understanding that's where a lot of the
vitriol seems to stem from based on her
past views on certain subjects but the
thing about it is the crazy thing about
it is and again not getting into the
political side of it if you really look
at the things that Collin Moriarty's
been vilified for its BS its BS we got
into that but it's kind of ridiculous
that you have this sort of movement
against certain opinions that people
have that aren't even you know everybody
has a right to be offended or not
offended by whatever at the same time if
you're looking at it as as as a person
who tried me trying to be objective and
trying to be as fair as possible this
stuff isn't it doesn't even touch the
surface of being horrific in a way that
to have people being sort of Oh X
singled out and then attacked in this
way it's sort of ridiculous listen when
your information is on the net and
somebody can access it by a click of a
button
and it's like it's there the the level
of insanity that can ensue from that
moment on you can't control it so there
was perfectly right to shut everything
down
it closed everything up and to get it
off as quickly as possible so you know
to them for doing that you don't know
the level of damage that it already has
caused and what will happen from it and
everybody's holding their breath hoping
that you don't have a situation that
escalates from this breach well it's not
even a breach if it was the full book
out dentistry it was and on on on
everybody's level everybody's gonna sit
there and try it cuz it's one person
that probably had the oversight of that
it's gonna boil down everybody's gonna
get the name of the person with
footprints all over the place it's first
it was one person that gave the goal
they clicked a button and allowed it to
happen now it wasn't her all right so
why she'd be vilified but we also know
when you make this little political
things there's a lot of political things
when it goes behind the scenes people be
saying just trying all this up I don't
get it today young you know I don't get
into nerd stuff I'm here to play video
games but when the people's our safety
that's when I take issue to that you
have to understand that these are normal
people go to the supermarket they can't
afford bodyguards
and you know they live at home with
their children they take the children to
school and you're putting that whole
household in jeopardy once this happens
and that's something that you should
take very seriously because you don't
want any nut job that there wants to say
oh I really like PlayStation are really
like Xbox and I didn't like your view on
this and I'm stupid
alright so shouted let's get up in a
room shout look shout to Sophie for
doing the right thing because at the end
of the day you know I got first and I
spoke to hole right I got first hand
that she went to him from a legal
standpoint she went to the ESA she went
to two other sources before leaking the
story right so in my opinion if she
really was about to click in the joint
you just put to join up right you
and I'm saying and whatever whatever so
she went she went did that first so in
my opinion is respect secondly it's not
a vulnerability like a no sale right
it's easily accessible file that says
you know link so it's like at the end of
the day it's like yes say like what we
really will be doing here like how does
this happen like how does lapsing jerk
yeah media and journalists downloadable
spreadsheet there's literally like click
me I'm here you know they like this just
terrible or or so many levels guide
attic anything she should be commended
and she should be appreciated for
showing that people could get your info
that easy but what it is is people are
blaming her for the spread of it so fast
I mean and it's just like look like if
she would if she wouldn't have noticed
that and first of all someone sent her
the information that it was leaked so it
was already out there like that they're
just lucky that someone found it found
it that was a respectable person I
didn't just leaked it
he privately emailed someone he knew it
had Dench handled because he didn't know
what to do yeah I mean you know I get it
and at the end of the day it's like you
know date to me these guys are still
responsible for having the information
out in the situation it was you know I'm
saying so you know that that to me is
the real issue but on the other side of
it you got to look at it like this like
the personal effect like I'm an industry
bachelor right so this affects me you
know these so anyone who deals with like
IT and like government you know I'm
saying like Pete call it they call it P
I so basically it's personal
identification all right so that right
there they strict strict policies you
know I'm saying on that like very strict
so you got like to the point where you
have to take a course to actually
maintain your axis in order to have
access to that joint use enough time so
at the end of the day like they are in
serious trouble like serious trouble
like I have no idea how that happens and
we got
after math you know say we got to see
what's gonna happen as a result you know
legally you know it's if they're gonna
arm the lawsuits we know there's a lot
of big names involved you know I'm
saying as far as like companies the
Goldman Sachs all that other stuff you
know I'm saying like this this is such a
cataclysmic botch for them with them
already being on the decline and miss
handling that PII and here's the other
thing y'all
that's United States government rules
for PII how you handle personal
information right the people on this
list a lot of them are European right
they got this other thing called a GDP
or like they got their own legal set at
the end of the day if they want to press
each of them individually consume the
ESA they come off so like they are in
big trouble like people to understand
like this is a big deal you know I'm
saying so I don't know and then you got
like the last thing I'm just gonna say
it's like how confident moving forward
our people going be we trusted them with
the information you know I'm saying
that's what I go on this check okay so
it's scary man it's really scary and
it's just I don't know like the timing
again I don't know sitting not
conspiracy theory or anything like that
but it's the timing is it's kind of
crucial because if if this does become a
big thing that question that you asked
like okay so being that if the e3 is in
this sort of state of flux where does it
go if people don't have the confidence
in it anymore
right if the people who go and cover the
games and this don't have the confidence
anymore how does that change what does
what this show ultimately becomes you
know I mean so I don't I don't really
feel that III some flux I'm not gonna
run with that narrative because that
lends to a whole different side of the
ball um we were in a transition year and
it was a prudent upon a couple couple of
companies they didn't have where's the
show and economically it wasn't
financially advisable to step forward
and do certain errands but other people
that were at e3 e3 was III it was the
same normal III that has time to when it
turned in
to the tradeshow the belief that it had
record crowds just like before um and
also you know on the merch and
information was being out the way we
consume information now is on a higher
level it's saying that the way we
consume information now is on a higher
level that same information as people
information should not be readily
available for anybody to click on and
eat your address that is severely
troublesome if you look it's crazy if
you look at the the picture they put up
with the Kotaku article right it's like
it's yeah it's a register it's a it's a
link that's readily there and then the
20 thing is they warn you what comes
after the link it says registered media
list and it says please note this list
shows registered media contacts as of
May 30th 2019 so it's telling you what's
coming behind it how how is this reached
how is this when you you have it readily
available and then you know the
sensitivity of the information because
you give a disclaimer before and like I
say for all this pitch forking against
Sophia like it was up before she you
don't say like it up so who knows you
don't it listen man here's the other
thing too we got to keep it real right
like at the end of the day it's like we
all got our opinions and our views right
same thing with journalists we all got
our favors and we got people who I don't
necessarily care for the opinion so
could you imagine some nutjob you and
I'm saying like running down because
this is scary stuff I can't I lived
through on you know a lot of you know
super stars or whatever getting run down
on because they're the information and
stuff got out now on a lower level well
you can't even say low level because our
entertainment
I would chosen form of media that we
choose to consume our stuff with is
actually bigger than movies bigger than
TV it's the highest form of
entertainment
so that our stars you know the Collins
and stuff like that these guys are on
the front line you know and um Twitter
spreads like wildfire so if a guy gets a
screenshot of somebody's address and
posted it on Twitter or whatever and it
just spreads across do you understand
the level of damage that this can cause
this is out of control
what it is is and what the fear is now
who is gonna pay out who is going to be
accountable Oh someone's gonna get
prepped because at the end of the day
you're talking big money now you're
talking you talk about all sort of
people affiliated it's like goldman
sachs these type of people affiliated
with the information and stuff leak
they're going to press the esa there's
going to be big dog lawyer talk going on
behind the scenes and they may have to
settle but that wall so we don't even
know how much bread they got some ways
oh yeah that's like this could be a
finishing blow finish let's say they
survived it right then who's good what
media journalists is gonna in full
confidence trust them to be like alright
103 next year
nobody three next year let's do it like
a week we'll do three if you're not
involved that's what I got on this arm
Lord at look first of all shout to the
chat I know you're saying we got a lot
of mic issues please bear with us we've
got a lot of things going on right now
OBS and then apparently yetis have been
bugging out my yetis acting a little
crazy so if I sound low I apologize and
if AG sounds too high he apologized
because there's an update that got our
yetis acting out of wack so we're trying
to work through this so how's bear with
us how's that
Lord adequate you brought baby don't
worry about the mic man I think this
drop down there he's gone back in so uh
yeah yeah we basically Lord addict was
gonna talk about mixer you know some
signing a ninja so uh let's up bring
this to the to the realm you know say
start up with us solve like what do you
feel solve about this big move by
Microsoft I mean for people who care
about the stuff and I'm one that doesn't
I got I said I don't really watch people
play games like that I know it's a big
deal especially to a lot of lot of
younger gamers I mean that's kind of
what they've grown up with I don't mind
my nephew like he just loves watching
people do stuff on on YouTube like
whatever like when he was younger he was
like unboxing videos of stuff of toys
and like things like that now it's like
people playing for tonight he loves
watching that stuff so I don't get it
but I get how big it is um and the fact
that yeah the biggest streamer on Twitch
has now moved to mixer is a big deal
it's a big deal for mixer I don't know
just famouser I'm sorry he's not the
biggest dreamer so I was corrected oh
really okay so I stand corrected the
biggest dreamer is the smoke ninja bang
don't put it in the chat what's to do
who smoked ninja like he was a newbie
and they'll put that in the chat so we
could give the shout out to the name of
of the dude what is it to to fruit to
fool a fool t fools you top anyway
we got the second piece we got the
run-up but yeah yeah so question again
what you guys who use mixer more his
mixer kind of in trouble well this this
is the vibe I I got the vibe I got from
them is that they're like look they're
kind of a fledgling platform with slow
growth right but they've been in third
place the reality it's still Amazon with
twitch Google
with YouTube and then them right but
it's not that they've been failing it's
just a data therapist do but they've
been having slow growth but as far as
feature wise the latency is way better
or mixing that that's one of my reasons
why me actually liking it because the
chat to talk ratio it's very quick right
I mean that's what I when they first
announced me what was the other name the
the original name of mixer before they
switched it to make sure what was it
called right so remember that when they
switched it over the mixer and they
announced all of these like these
quality of life improvements the first
thing you notice is that when it came to
like resolution of streaming the the
latency all that stuff kind of blew
twitch out of water and people thought
wow this is gonna be a huge paradigm
shift and it didn't happen just because
the how massive twitch is so I to see
that you know they're making moves to
try to solidify that and continue to
grow it is is is cool I think it's
something that's necessary in in the
gaming environment in this day and age
again doesn't appeal to me but I think
it's important and then people for
people running with that narrative day
they'd rather spend 50 million dollars
on a streamer and not it not a and not a
triple-a game like you know what hold on
to that thought wait a couple of years
if the games that are coming out of
their their first party acquisitions and
the new stuff coming out of these
studios and not up to snuff go right
ahead and run with that narrative until
just whatever like it's it's foolish you
back sir I see you back know you're
working a Mike issue but um let me know
a few records we're gonna get your
tapping will make sure you went on this
but until then Tom King yeah check it
out when um when ninja came over his
first stream I think they did a hundred
thousand right off the rim eighty
thousand something like that more than
anybody else's on the right
there's money well-spent those are
eighty thousand to a hundred thousand
eyes on whatever game he's playing now
imagine when those are first parties
Microsoft games you know Microsoft is
learning a lesson that they had with the
zoom
was a superior product to the little um
I touch whatever and it died the reason
why it died it wasn't nobody behind it
wasn't you know everybody cool was
behind the Apple stuff so I'm unless I
understand he's not at his peak right
now but he has enough of a fanbase that
you'd bring him over and he's gonna
bring eyes to other ever topic or
whatever game that you have there and
he's never play it now you get this big
streamer because I don't really watch
people play games but it's a ton of
people do right eighty thousand so a
hundred thousand shows you that the eyes
are there and his money well-spent when
marketing looks over and said see I told
you they want it's a hit boy comes over
he hits a home run when that next Halo
launches over there and he's playing
Halo competitively and all those
streaming views and everybody wants to
be cool like ninja and he climbs up the
ladder and it has like kognito said the
latency is better people get a chance to
look at the platform in a different view
and it makes it hip and makes it cool
that moves what Microsoft is trying to
do is build a foundation you just can't
walk in and have the Taj Mahal built you
had to lay one brick so you can upset
with them laying one brick and you
saying but what about the games they
just brought divisions these gods
actively working on games what you want
them to be a one-trick pony and don't
actually diversify the portfolio you
know what I have to I have no choice
this could where game it so if you're
not gonna have faith in your console
then move on to the next station
upstairs I get every first party game
that comes out guess will get dust on it
and I'm not and if you don't have great
game they have great games I just don't
like the ecosystem and the environment
another thing we talk about the ESA I
don't feel safe with them my information
is readily available at the click of a
hat people could be driving around in
their new Corvette with my name
no idea what's going on with those dudes
and I don't trust them
Microsoft and if every problem that if
that's a problem for you want you to put
up the sheets the receipts or how many
times Microsoft has been busted wide
open and your information from Microsoft
suite and how many times Sony's
information hit you I don't feel safe I
know active PlayStation players who
don't put a live credit card on a joint
for a reason now all fraud me and tell
me you put a lot if you put your you
won't put your back against that
PlayStation you want to back your
playstation up you want to back that
Sony situation put your card or put your
arse on deck and then after somebody
goes approaches 40 or 50 PlayStation
pros and run your account to the ground
and kill you bro we got nothing to do it
shame on you
so King I gotta ask you though so I have
no doubt he's gonna play Halo right halo
oh yeah that years years but that's the
thing do you think they're gonna part of
the deal is for him to play games
I know halo I know he's playing that
everything else though like if they'd be
like you're means I need you to play I
need you to play what he's on be on it
he's gonna be on everything that drops
out fresh right now everything that
drops out fresh is definitely on game
pass all right so that's a win-win so
now when he's streaming up you can play
like ninja right now no game pad you can
challenge ninja right now in a game on
xbox in game pass right follow us on mix
I don't care what anybody says this is
building blocks stepping forward if
you're telling me that you upset at a
company putting a best foot forward
they lost his generation sir like that
loss so what you want them to do because
what they was doing was not working
ranging it up you getting upset like
it's funny though cause somebody I like
I said I get it this is not something
that I get because it's not something
I'm into right but as somebody like
looking at it from the outside you say
yeah man you spent money on this dude
and you know why didn't you spend money
on you know keeping that Call of Duty
exclusivity stuff you know I mean like
that's been like it's stuff like that
that makes you work like makes you think
about it you know why I can tell you why
I can tell you why when the Call of Duty
comes out
ninjas gonna be playing it'll mix up we
got this is juicy this is juicy BAE a
beam tell you right now when it comes to
this situation everybody's gonna look
back at it y'all seen the footprints
because he's leaving in us and he wanna
understand at the end of the show when
the Taj Mahal is built and you and I'm
we standing right there next to good I
would follow his ways let me tell you
something I'm gonna tell y'all a reach
back I will put my hand out and say
listen join us this is okay it's okay
good moves I'll be leading the charge
it's just not too long ago y'all was on
a ninja train you go right back on that
menu train when Cole training these
dudes is doing a thing in September
there's a wolf fire between a dream if
ninja we're like a
use words that you gonna eat is very
short words is coming for the same oh my
god
mix it your favorite reaming service my
favorite juice I'll go how they gave
Minji the bag and give you the bag and
you've been there first oh my god I just
cry at night looking about money that I
could have had my hands off of this
dream team now that we're getting into
this whole thing I see mixer has made
the announcement like what are your
thoughts on this whole process between
you know mixer ninja and the effects yes
so so there's I feel like there's
multiple things that are gonna be coming
up from this now there's a lot of
amazing things that are gonna happen for
mixer and there's a lot of amazing
things that are gonna happen for twitch
and being someone that's been in the
twitch community and being in that
streaming community for a really long
time I see that the mixer community is
definitely gonna grow it's gonna get
bigger and it's getting a little
stronger because of ninja moving over
there and it's also going to help a lot
of the smaller streamers in the church
community because those people that are
gonna be normally watching ninja and
have an allegiance to twitch aren't
gonna leave twitch and they're just
gonna go and find another person to to
view so I think it's good I think it's
gonna be really interesting
as for the what Ninja has done I think
it's for him really dicey because I
personally think that from what I've
seen with mixer is that they plateau
with viewers I feel like there's they
don't have that many people coming in
what
he say hold assault slow though he's on
your head already early do you not these
are internal discussions that we have a
glad yes yes I'm not I'm not anti mixer
beyond what most people think I might me
personally I think that it really has
plateaued
but with ninja coming in it's gonna
revitalize a lot of those people that
are gonna be moving over these now
you've used baby
he's ninjas got some vision that's
that's essentially what's gonna happen
people are going to end up starting to
see that and and that's great and I
think that with ninja moving over it's
going to be a great thing for Microsoft
because it's gonna allow them to grow
and to be able to get their name out
will get a lot of their games out that
most people are not used to seeing on a
regular basis which is you know what I
think is going to be interesting and
everybody knows Micra the only reason
why ninja ended up moving over there is
because they got money got body by T
food yeah I'm talking with respectable
but not knowing crash into my chat it
was bad he got body oh man nothing is
dicey about a guarantee they said is
basically gonna be the Xbox mixer
spokesman that's not dicey they don't
like you're dicey Snape know what Mazen
else's job Jonathan be you know I do
like when you in the chat I really do
appreciate about like to see it in color
hi I've said it before I think what
ninja did was smart for ninja that was a
good decision for him right Curtis uh
from the rumors that I've heard I've
heard that like when he ended up
starting to play apex legends from
fortnight they
they gave him a cool like ei was like
here's a million dollars boom play apex
legends but so if they're giving him a
million dollars to play one game for
like six months three months whatever
the deal might have been think about
what they ended up doing with mixer
because when he left when he left twitch
what people don't realize is that when
you're affiliated not even partnered you
have to sign a contract with them right
like I am affiliated with twitch right I
have a signed contract with them stating
that I cannot I cannot strong which I've
never hided this whatsoever when you
sign with them they like a lot of people
they don't read that paperwork they
don't they don't read it they're just
like I'm just gonna sign it because this
is what they want to do it states that
we cannot stream at the same time mixer
and what you know competitor where you
cannot multicast to two platforms right
you can that stream to twitch you can
complete that stream call it a day then
you can shoot a mixer complete that do
that you KITT you cannot when you are
affiliated with twitch you cannot stream
to mixer hold on with show total was
like a beauty file super chance yeah but
Bratz the only ninja exclusive on what
is to go to Xbox ends with the word gay
yeah we don't know what you're talking
about sir anyway um smell go question
right does that sound like fair like
you're giving a non-compete they can't
do it at the same time is there are they
afraid that somebody might sue the
stream I would mix it this is they get a
side-by-side comparison at the same time
they might be showed up they do
a switch situation I will not say it's a
switch situation whatsoever I think it's
what what I think is is that twitch
thinks that once these individuals get
to their statuses of partnership that
they they want to keep them as partnered
now I think it was about a year and a
half ago Facebook mixer I don't know
about you two but I know Facebook a
mixer for a fact ended up finding twist
streamers that were stagnant about aha
two hundred to a hundred and change
streamers and they would end up going to
them ago hey we're gonna give you a
contract to come over and join mixer
we're gonna give you partnership and
blah blah blah they ended up walking
over to them and people would end up
going alright I'm doing it and they
would get bit because those streamers
are gonna want to look like they can
live for the rest of their lives
they want to be able to work for the
rest of their lives streaming and we
knew that stagnant point it is really
really hard and when when you hit that
partnership you they see those content
creators and they go oh we're gonna keep
them here we're gonna sign those clauses
and for some people that's that's fine
that's fantastic that's what they want
to do that's cool but for other people
they want more and we're we're ninja was
where he was he pretty much was just
like on the [ __ ] on I don't give a crap
with Sunday sorry
like I don't care but yo sorry for
second colors my man Jonathan B just
gotten them color I me purse the reason
why I stay with twitch is because that's
where the community that I built and
grown is I'm too small to say hey I'm
out of here
see you later bye like that's why I
under that's all the people that I've
known and I worked with and that's what
I do or people that are on mixer you
know they're gonna feel very similar
that the people that they stream what
they host and things like that what that
twitch that was all baby yesterday baby
is just the day I bring this mixer Ninja
has shown it away widget has sliced me
all the rhetoric he made the past the
bag too you have just stated that ninja
will raise everybody's sales [ __ ] has
stepped into the port everybody both is
high now everybody will give eat eat the
streaming life fantastic water because
the ninja has shown you the way and you
continue to stay you'll contract at
teach love my question for you is that
if you were partnered with I'm sorry if
you were subscribed to ninja over in
twitch right and he's got X amount of
users over there now he literally has
tweeted and stated I have gone to mixer
right you come over to mixer I will sub
you over there so you have all these
people I don't know what the equivalent
to two mixes two mixers subscription
plan is for the user base that's gonna
watch so what we need to see is not
what's happening right now you don't
want to see like because losers
for everyone to come over to his channel
right now he has all these followers is
all these people over there now for them
to come over so what we want to talk a
lot or like an Italian Dave so so what
we really really need to see is what's
gonna happen long term we need to see
what's gonna happen in two or three
months soldiers don't get me wrong I
think that what he did was smart for him
and I wanted more mean a lot about you
some nice
listen there come September when the
gears drop and ninjas playing gears that
will be the highest viewed gaming shown
on mixer that day
ninja boots it up and it gets the
popping listen I'm not I'm not gonna
first put knees or bets on what I'm
gonna happen no matter what you're gonna
have ninja
whatever he plays is going to be top
over there because he produces like a
lot of you get content that a lot of
people come over to him how are people
gonna compete when you're sitting there
streaming and you have Drake playing
with you in your channel if you have
players playing your channel this way
there you can compete with that I'm
sorry but I think that whatever he's
they may employ strategies with him
similar to that or encourage him to do
that as far as well as Marcus sauce
first party our lineup you know is it
more of a marketing play as opposed to
just a traditional you're just coming
over to mixer thing you know no no I
think it's definitely it's definitely
got to be marketing for them because if
you look at any of the larger streamers
any of them you will see them getting
lots of games that are first party brand
new things that are there everyone's
gonna watch I've see streamers that you
know when they end up are the top of the
top I'm talking like Tim the tap man you
can co carnage I'm talking all those
guys when they get games their streams
which are usually like you know two or
three thousand a day yeah going up to 15
20 K a day so that's that's just because
of the games and they know that's what's
gonna happen
and I know that this has been a long
ride in discussion with Dave that people
from twitch should be getting money to
market their games because you're played
privilege getting their games for free
they should be getting on the bankroll
they should be getting money for that
and I agree with that and interest
taking that steps that are saying yeah I
will take your money thank you very much
[Music]
Dominus Maximus how you feel about ninja
and the whole thing you know as far as
him is whether he's on the decline all
that we got it me you know what they're
trying to do is far as position mixer as
a new entity to be on we saw the
short-term effect as the app and what to
like number one
yeah the app store whatever whatever
right okay cool but the short-term
effects its kind of paying off already
with that and hits fan base you know I'm
saying it's gonna come over but to me
the way I look at it is being at
Microsoft was in there more entrenched
in this services game right now right
the game past the X cloud right to me he
kind of fits in line with that
so I think you know you know that is on
right now all right shout out to restore
it Hades with the $10 super chat ninja
didn't do anything different for sports
athlete they grow as a free agent then
they cash out plus they just said he
wants to get back to his roots aka halo
overall this is a good decision salute
the restore hey I was just about to get
into that the thing the thing I'm saying
is this is like tell him he's you onto
something because I understand the
foresight coming forward don't you think
that this is like a three prong approach
nito was just alluding to the services
so you're gonna gain past its hitting
there right now we're gonna stream this
to you all those games that's in game
pass is gonna be played by the top dude
that you know because people not over
here the top is over here or mixer right
so now allow two personnel them when
ninja stop streaming and all those dudes
is like they're like man what's the next
thing man what's on and they click over
the yo channel who did definitely with
the thing the thing what a lot of people
don't realize is that when you are part
of the community even like ninja has
produced and he has moved over to mixer
people have allegiances to the streamers
that they watch mm-hmm I know that I
have certain individuals that I watch
and I watched them on mixer and I
watched them on Twitch I will go back
and forth between the two right but the
thing is is that I will always watch the
person that I prefer to watch amit sadh
mixer if it's on twitch it's just like
if anyone wants to watch something on
Netflix or if they're gonna watch
something on Hulu if if someone's your
favorite right you're gonna go with your
right like that if someone's that big
and influential you're gonna go where
they're at so it's going to have I'm not
saying you disagree I know you go it's
gonna have a short-term effect to me I
just look at it the overall scheme of
why Microsoft is doing its like this
doesn't into their mole they're going
services they're going with all this
stuff and then halo we all know a little
infinite is going to be a launch title
for scarlet right immediately in the
press conference your man is talk about
his halo roots talking about how much he
loved and all this other stuff
make no mistake in my opinion the
marketing blitz is gonna be crazy with
him in front of that I'm with you all
the way okay when addict put this did
this topic up in the chat I laugh
I laughed it off I swear adding is a
profit I don't know any of these do if
it wasn't for addict and PD telling me
who to use be like I don't know max is
my reminder packs it's like I'm out
there with Danna tidge writes out the
dance is lord - is the man there's also
the man no disrespect I gotta be honest
he's the most this just dissing I'm like
oh well he's the coolest dude I didn't
know his stature you know I'm saying so
you'll just show you the generational
data we have a guy can continue is there
okay so but my thing is this right I'm
one of those dudes that I can be
watching somebody do a stream and I'll
see cuz I don't know anybody and I going
to a party and you're tough to people
and you get you know when when cognate
on nine was at that what was that what
was that the church party in Boston what
was that loser we met wicked I'm not and
I wasn't mixing well I said when we met
wiki whatever that party it was a jump
off party right we know no one going in
but everybody was shaking hands and
kissing babies right you want to know
one of them people so if I see Schneider
I look up and the first thing you do you
look up at presentation okay so maybe
your presentation is not all that that
you're not pulling people in all right
but you show me a whole lot of things
that I have no idea about like like when
somebody sends money through when you
get a new sub how to put a little or
graphics up and stuff like that I had no
idea about that stuff that stuff is way
beyond me
but when I see it happening it's
pleasing to my eyes right
so I become a new follower to that
person now if I came over just because
of ninja and just stopped upon streaming
upon but I'm still up eating my Cheetos
and I want to see who's next up I want
to find the next ninja who say you not
the next ninja you all mix it but you're
not because you're on Trichy this is
where this is happening for you this is
that's happening for you
that next person up that's gonna catch
the attention of that kid that adult
that person that wants that streaming
realness they're gonna get it and it's
because they brought this guy over if
they don't bring them over they don't
get that sub they don't get that extra
I'm not saying it's a bad thing it's a
great thing because you cannot we lost
on all fronts you understand so when
you're trying to get back and you trying
to get confidence of the people you got
to get confidence all the way through
you just take the confidence just
because you brought a studio and you put
out a game right it's a generational
thing me soft King we're not used to it
right but you know this generation they
follow their topstreamers they go to
where these guys are going it in like
case in point see if these was kind of
dead for a bit right and then I forgot
who it was popular streamer they start
streaming it consistently and then all
of a sudden it kind of like shoots
through the roof so that's like the new
marketing now right then no marketing is
the favorite streamer playing the game
and then people kind of going off so I
think ultimately this is a halo infinite
push mmm this is a scarlet launch push
um I think and I agree repeat IDO
contractually twitch because I know
people like oh touches penny for cutting
him so quick contrarily they had to do
that right like that that's just part of
the thing but um I think they setting up
a play I think they're setting up a play
this is a next generation of play and
it's going to be interesting to see you
know if their strategy you know pulls
off for them because um I didn't expect
this I didn't I'll be on it and the
other question I got for yours do you
think as a result more of the bigger
guys say hey if you don't ninja got the
bag over there
good email make a brother ice cream
we're already seeing that effect yeah
it's it's all it's all about the money
they for streamers I mean and addict
will agree with me if you're gonna pay
me enough I'll do whatever the hell you
want me to do good if Microsoft called
me right now and said hey Pete I want
you distri
every day on mixer I'll be like beauty
Lisa I can bag off he kind of you heard
that I would I weren't I'd listen I mean
as addict and others would say like not
oh I'm Bank yes I being a stream right
now it is difficult to which Noah
holding you to twist nothing just a bag
slid your way because you to sign your
allegiance over very quickly but you got
to remember you can think about this in
in the way the way of a streamer is that
their community means everything if I
end up cutting my ties to twitch and
going over to mixer all the friends and
people that I admit on twitch they're
not gonna want to host me they're not
gonna want to come to my channel anymore
now go I'm gonna give you an email
saying I'm gonna give you a New York
sing scared money don't make no money
all right whoa I'm gonna tell you this
if you that do it over there and twitch
you to do it over there mixer you
started from the bottom you can start
again there's nothing to scrap it to
start all over if ninja not afraid don't
be afraid say ninja got the bag though
you understand what you got to do it is
not a statement I've got to have a
context exclusive I don't want you to
miss I mean maybe this you're lame now
don't let's only ninja coming here
Bogart you strapped so so let's get
let's get Phil Spencer on the phone so
you st. Peter your sell out to you just
st. Bernard for the right money you are
I'm not saying I'm not a star
I made it very openly to the dr contact
for Kingdom Hearts 3 that I will easily
sell out to that we both have agreed on
that it's a long time ago too long
hit me up man right now on what yet
topping man so like what did you think
man what's the effect here the ninja
effect like people like you see here
trying to act like this dude went from
like the number one spot on Twitch to
like having like not even a thousand
followers like look is he as big as he
used to because fortnight's kind of on
the decline sure he's not as big but
when I'm gonna share an act like he's
not the top five content creators on
huge and Microsoft reach their hand in
the bag it said that's my like could you
say that he had the most recognizable
name out of that top five I think he
knows I guess I think ninjas the most
recognizable with streamer in the world
right now so you leave it right oh sure
to us breaking a hundred watching like
fun problem on even and please hit those
like buttons it helps out wrong way
please hit the like y'all yes thank you
like like I've like a lot of people
don't realize is that he is the only
gaming individual that has ever been put
on the cover of ESPN so that is a big
deal for the gaming community and he is
definitely known for that let alone you
know half of his streaming stuff but
this I think this is a great deal for
for for Microsoft because they're gonna
be able to get a lot of their games out
and a lot of things to be seen and you
know what I think this was really the
device for like people could sit there I
did see people on Twitter that's like oh
he he's not gonna play this he's not
gonna play that I guarantee you he's
gonna make some kind of open public
announcement that he's playing games on
the next Xbox like this there's more to
this than just straight me yep like you
don't give someone that much money
without more
one moment yo could you imagine what's
what's gonna happen is first off Heil is
gonna be way bigger than it was then it
was going to be without him
because look what happened to Apex
legends you know just having someone
like you know obviously is more than
ninja that was streaming FX legends that
got its what it was but ninja was
definitely like one on the front lines
right it's like you know and then you
have the domino effect ninja leaving
means more people are gonna leave with
them don't get it twisted there is
fanboys for streamers too you're gonna
have people naturally go over to make
sure just cuz he's there mmm-hmm I mean
what this halo pros the liquor made
sounds right that ain't ready to make
nice for themselves by destroying your
petty this other people your business
that's just gonna see here's the thing
like you know Microsoft might not go
that direction where they're like you
know you have to stream on the Xbox they
probably won't but they're going to I
guarantee you they're big exclusives
he's gonna be playing what maybe not
years but I bet you he's gonna be
playing out a world which he probably
was gonna play that game anyway that's
done oh wow so it doesn't matter it's
the whole brand to their first party
studio like whatever they sell is so
good for them like doesn't play Gears I
don't see them making him play something
he wouldn't play out of the norm I bet
you're feeling that gives oh I have a
feeling I have a feeling the Ninja is
gonna get every single game that they're
gonna find like he's gonna get them all
and the thing is is that with the whole
entire
system of every streaming service is
that the first person that gets the game
is the first person that gets the views
is the first person that gets the money
so they're gonna end up giving they're
gonna give him let's say halo infinite a
week before everybody else he's good and
he's gonna be getting I can guarantee if
anything that I I don't think this was
solely done for Halo and mine but I it
was one of the biggest motors that it
like look like it might cost us a lot of
money they're looking at it like they
are try to set off that next generation
with such a bang from the hardware
sector and the marketing and in the
influence aspect like I didn't have a
question for King I just couldn't reason
the ninja on stage I do have a question
for you do you think that the big
commotion for ninja because like now
ninjas nothing yeah niche is not a
streamer no one's going to mixer like do
you think that we're getting this kind
of reaction because mixer is a Microsoft
product yes it's only had their own
their own tablet will obviously mixtures
and I can really established its a brand
if Sony what I had one and ninja order
went there people would have said that's
genius at it what does Sony have okay
catch on by extreme amount put it on the
holy stranded only stream we'll be using
our PS now and they would be going
probably going for a hoard star I just
got a free cuz I don't know where they
got over when they did the what's that
YouTube thing they do every year the
commercial they do every year saying
what happened that year last year it had
Will Smith in the beginning of it I
don't know it's PlayStation I don't know
talking about YouTube YouTube does that
YouTube rewind that's what it's for
everyone
ninja was in that and he don't even he's
not even YouTube that's how big you
ninja it was in a YouTube commercial
when he just posts his highlights on
YouTube he's not even an active
influencer on YouTube and he's and he is
in the yearly thing for YouTube and I
saw TMZ major PewDiePie isn't even in
that major news outlets it's all you
know I think I think I think Microsoft
just go just bought a bag of by a buddy
I think they should go over there take
all of you Sony guys free which stream
is agent income and put them where you
don't want to watch yes but should we
feel a certain way that you know there's
exclusive streams but I'd exclusive can
show up they will play like I was
thinking before about a year ago mixer
was doing this before Microsoft was
going over it they were buying streamers
left and right hundred you could take
all that work they did combine it in
times it by 100 and still doesn't touch
yeah that's insane did that's this is
this is something that I feel that
Microsoft probably tested last year to
see if it was worth them to spend the
money right and then they were like oh
this works this is legit let's go after
ninja you know what's funny happening
I'm sit here thinking do you think this
is the last
Furret all mixer it's a ninja thing
fellows like I think no extra might be a
rat because like this feels like this
feels like desperation to be honestly
this is like that moment they're like
okay mixtures not doing anything what we
want it to do here's the bag go fix it
like this feels like the last stretch
this is our last the same things good
addict away the thing is is that mixer
is actually bigger in South America than
it is the US so there are other
countries that mixer is actually bigger
on because the bandwidth usage on Twitch
is actually higher than mixer so the
reason why we better in lower economical
places which I don't even know how you
saw that it wasn't colored I'm about no
no no right no he's not posting that for
a minute so I would since inaudible
jumps on he's been talking about latency
I think he but firstly their blood
vessel he sees everything is red I just
read all chat while I'm down with dizzy
oh that like I'm just saying that like I
think that what the whole entire thing
that Microsoft did with grabbing the Joe
was very very smart for them and I think
in the end it is gonna make it vastly
more profitable for Microsoft in the
long run it's just gonna be very
interesting to see how it is going to
progress and to see because how many new
games are coming out for Microsoft
within the next you know a couple of
months between now in the end of the
year years so it would be interesting to
see between now and the end of the year
to see how it seems like report which I
can see ninja playing player which I
know because I feel like that's gonna be
a streaming game English but like when
we get codes that we have to review and
we won't finish we have to do you know
so much yeah I guess ninja you don't get
codes you have to review get codes they
beggin you to review I don't have to
review anything I'm dead all easy
Almighty
please put there in color sovereign Oh
skipping okay no I mean we could do that
or we could do it you know I figure we
got PD here so let's just get this song
you don't say it's because we are packs
of people so to speak we're accepted by
packs this is packs west we go to pax
east you know we go we go act like we
got a difference just go long with the
soft go yes
so two weeks ago now our Colin Moriarty
had confirmed to his um to the viewers
and listeners of his PlayStation podcast
of sacred symbols that he was finally
making a return to to to uh basically
like a public forum he hadn't been to e3
in quite some time since he went on his
own he hadn't been to any of these
events um and he finally decided to
submit for a panel at PAX West for his
PlayStation podcast sacred symbols um he
got accepted and so he immediately told
his his fan base that hey we're gonna be
there we're gonna have a Q&A session
just talk to you guys or whatnot um so
you know go out if you want to come see
us we're gonna be there we'll do a meet
you mean I gonna do a meet-and-greet or
whatnot but would gladly answer
questions take photos whatever it's
gonna be a cool time and it's gonna be
my my first return to like a public
forum so a little while after that pax
contacts him indicating that they
canceled his panel just a little bit of
background on Colin Moriarty I know
we've all heard it before but Colin was
one of he initially was part of i GN he
was part of podcast beyond which is big
pretty much the biggest PlayStation
podcast for quite some time he was one
of the cofounders of kind of funny and
when they broke off
their playstation podcast became huge
with him and Greg Miller and then he
broke off from kind of funny in a
controversial way I know we addressed it
here on the show as well as what
happened with that um and since then
Colin has he has felt and I think I've
seen it myself as well that he's been
sort of blacklisted in in regard this is
definitely confirmation of that he's
been sort of blacklisted when it comes
to you know media media tie and you know
what's even worse about this all was
like when he got invited to that I bet
you it was like oh man might not be
blacklisted yeah this is amazing and
then two weeks later never mind
right oh he said it in in a in a tweet
he said it was stupid of me to think
that old stuff wasn't gonna get in the
way like he felt like I felt bad you
know like they had that new PR team that
reached out to us a little husband that
you got fired to ever had anything to do
with is like he all required that Colin
stich he had to get rid of all yes on
him
[Music]
no tarita canola which means like don't
get dressed cause you not go the
greatest thing that you could have told
me today numbers jump make sure I get
that brought my ticket all right so
which they have that they have the right
to cancel this panel without giving them
a real explanation they just can't so
but his thing was like okay fine you're
not giving me an explanation what about
the money I spent to go there after you
oh you told me to advertise the fact
that I was gonna be at your so Colin had
come back and forth with them saying
look I don't care look I don't want to
be where I'm not wanted
I want you to a reimburse me and my
co-host Chris Reagan reimbursed our you
know what we've done and you should also
reimburse people who bought tickets
specifically from my panel otherwise
we're not going to pax you should also
reimburse them so initially they have no
answer I know shoutout to ho-ho
kind of contacted him to get details
about what was going on and he did a
great of virtual legality honestly look
it up on hoax Channel
so basically they eventually started
answering him but basically said look
we're more than happy to reimburse you
and Chris for your flights and your and
your hotel they initially had offered
him he said your panel is canceled but
you could still have your free passes to
come so you can come to pax and be here
and spend the money okay you can't do
anything why promote don't talk to you
but you can buy the food here oh your
thing but you can definitely come and
you know spend money at our thing
so that was the first thing obviously
when he said no I'm not going
then they got like terms of services
such as don't talk to anyone
exactly so he decided like no that's not
happening so at the end of the day they
decided they're gonna reimburse his
costs for going but they definitely said
they are not reimbursing any but of his
fans and indicate and no longer going
because any shout-out to Hogue again for
for breaking us down when you buy a
ticket to pax you explicitly enter into
a contract with them basically like
buying a ticket for like a counter or
something like that and indicating that
you are willing to accept the fact that
whatever you're specifically going to
watch if it's just one thing may be
cancelled that you know the idea is you
should be buying a ticket for the entire
event and taking the entire event not
for a specific thing because they're not
selling tickets to a one specific thing
so that kind of relieves them of
liability anybody who bought tickets for
four just to see sacred symbols is is
out their money if they're not going
otherwise um so what Colin ultimately
did was he decided I think he's
reimbursing something like fifty or
fifty-five people something like that
out of his own pocket so Rick my thing
is this this man has been vilified since
he left kind of funny for reasons feel
like this ridiculous and over completely
ridiculous
I like Colin I like you know whatever
his his political affiliations are and
and and I don't think that is that crazy
either what the City study and
um the fact that matter is this good has
been in the gaming space for a very long
time he's a very knowledgeable person
when it comes particularly the
PlayStation stuff oh when he left kind
of funny
his channel was initially very like
politics oriented and a little by little
he he went back to his laws uneven when
he started that he said he wouldn't do
gaming stuff but once you cover gaming
news for certain mother he missed it
anyway that's not the case he may've had
plenty of bags what I you know what he
get this back basically the fans are out
there money he's getting back his his
flight tickets and whatever his flight
price or whatever in his hotel so what
do you guys think is there is there a
conspiracy question before we so I
thought so what what did Colin do to
make him they didn't he like they have
not explicitly explained never said no
no I mean I mean why did he originally
like why did they excommunicate him from
Pat's back cemented no he's blacklisted
from the industry in general I all in
the general yeah he made I don't know if
you remember this will cause him to
leave kind of funny but um I think it's
2017 now um the day you remember the
National Women's Day mom you're right it
was a thing where women weren't going to
work that day they were all it was a day
yeah it was hashtagged a day without a
woman so he posted a joke indicating he
said ah peace and quiet hash tag day and
that I mean his old friends turned on
him like looking for something all worst
yeah you covered it before you weaned
and we went in on their before and it up
I'm I know who he wasn't I didn't kid in
the thing is this right the funny part
about it is he got accepted right
somebody hit yes this was calculated cuz
it's beautiful this is a beauty birth
this is how you knock somebody out cold
right this is a setup yo you in the door
fax nope
oh stop promoting you
joint ready all right get these people
in him so all the people are signed up
right and I'm pretty sure there's more
than 55 people respect the healings
pulled in least probably like 300 people
all right so okay cool that's that's
fantastic do all that people showed up
then they pull the rug from under the
old boy feet I know you know what it is
it's a laughable funny moment because
it's funny because you thought you was
in you thought you don't got past
security when you buy concert tickets
for one show all right because if you
booked for that one person they can get
sick they can cancel anything happen so
that's that's on you that purchase that
ticket you thought Colin was gonna be
cleaned Oh Colin made it he's back again
you got Duke just like Colin the
difference between Colin is this when
they told him to promote actually became
liable for his ticket and all that other
and they told him promote right tell you
people that you're only because they
want his audience to beat it and hold
with it with it with the with the big
words promissory estoppel calling what
their fallout 76 been look you can't
find it cuz he don't even want that bad
you know hold up you bought a fallout 76
back no why do you have a cyst what is
it why is it in a bad thing
you know listen I know it's funny
initially we said it was hilarious it's
absolutely hilarious you got hung out
there and you know he was not supposed
to be in a club you know you look and
give this man about his it's it's funny
I don't see people here really like they
really like his stuff I don't know any
stuff but last time when Simon says
something I looked at it I felt that he
was unjustly vilified he made that
comment and yet believed the show and I
felt that was real yeah this is actually
hilarious yeah after I say this I have
to get going but um yeah that how it
goes is I feel like packs they need to
be there needs to be some kind of
backlash on there and like you can't
first off like if you're not willing to
make it right and offer refunds to the
people would there there's a difference
between someone getting sick and someone
being took out of the show when they
were invited two weeks they all that
they asked him to you know to promote
himself going to the show and then when
he gets there and he's about to go into
this you know a long thing he and he's
got a lot of followers so this probably
is they probably started refunding it
and then realized it was too many and
then they cut it off mmm it was like
look because they don't they don't have
a bylaw they don't have to refund
anybody Microsoft don't have to refund
no it is the right thing that - is it
the right thing to do sure they're not
gonna do it same weight same via live
from the ER hostel now he's on the
hospital Wi-Fi it is listening I
appreciate that brothers right now
brother right now that's my maze right I
just felt like pax pax needs some kind
of backlash like you're like if anything
the PR should get backlash because he's
like you know I did this man yo you back
like none of the mainstream media as an
outlet is attacking this right my
McCaffrey but too scared him McCaffrey
defended him defended him on his Twitter
and so did Brian altano butch because if
i GN is not going to touch this with a
with a ten-foot long stick and either
what was surprising is that Schreyer is
not touching it that's just wrong for
busy attacking homegirls let's call it
what it is I mean look do I agree with
everything Colin says no but at the end
of the day to be honest I've said some
really negative stuff about oh well you
know what I like I don't like when like
we got this culture like if it do your
rock with his political view or his
whatever then everything else afterwards
they're happy yeah or whatever you know
they're like I'm not with that like at
the end of the day it's like look man
they owe him an explanation as to why
two weeks out before the event they gave
them an acceptance letter saying you're
promoted to your audience tell people
PlayStation your show sacred symbols is
gonna be there they give them no reason
why they rescinded they not refunding no
money
you don't say and I'm saying like a
fight he had a fight they were trying to
slide him those passes and and that's it
look who Smith oh no I think when the
higher-ups realized what was going on
they shut it down like what it is I
think this is some kind of bias stuff
someone of the upper ends of PACs don't
like him it's all just say why you won't
you want to just say so like you know
it's a personal vendetta and then shout
out I mean hope specifically said it
Hoke said they have it is a their event
it's a private event they could tell you
they don't have to tell
but they can come on say I don't like
the way you look yeah I don't want you
there that's it and they they would be
within their rights to do this I don't
why you don't want him they want to make
actually like that he took dad's not
gonna do that
so shout out and shut out the Spartan
God he said Takashi at the end of the
day if you're gonna make a statement
like that like if you're gonna commit
and then and then and then just like
take the chips back it's like they gave
him that and they took it back like you
gotta make it right or you let me get
back like oh no about this dude two
weeks out how you don't know if you
really did water me how you don't know
to existence like a setup what they his
podcast they they're like kind of funny
doesn't really do a patient-centric
podcast no more soon as he brought this
podcast back it became the no.1
playstation podcast on the net here so
you're you're telling that the number
one playstation podcast that they cannot
go to a pax event yeah that's crazy
if it comes out if they got some
evidence of him saying some disparaging
joint when I'm saying they just need to
be clear just be clear and did just
refund this base that you told to
promote to come to beat it because let's
be real they wanted his base deal it's
not act like they didn't so looks a
banking jet you definitely definitely do
something for him even with an invite
now what a lot of people don't realize
is did you know did you notice where
League of Legends was when we were in
PAX East yeah where ryuk was yeah not on
the game floor the reason why is because
about three or four the four or five
years out I don't remember exactly when
there was an all-out brawl on the floor
on the stage floor because right gamers
were fighting other people like
fistfight
taken out of the floor and put them
somewhere else at the end of day it's
busy some reason I something really let
me do me finish this one point cladogram
some people have argued that they did it
because they've at the moment he was
announced that being at PAX and having
this panel that day there were threats
against his safety either directly
directed at him so that that's an
argument people have had but my thing
that's not an argument because I
guarantee you I guarantee that Jason
Schreyer has those same threats and he
gets invited that's the thing right it's
BS cuz one you still if you worried for
his safety
then why still offer him two passes to
come right I don't want you in a panel
because you're not a moving target babe
but if you're walking around the show
floor you know you're harder to kill go
right ahead
we don't want a sniper across the street
get in we want to make we want to make
their job eat hearty I don't want to
make it easy we don't want to give him a
platform to push his rhetoric you know
you just don't like him because he reps
that PlayStation break no I don't I can
actually honestly kill us about this he
didn't get it to pack so what I mean
you'll buy a ticket you want to stand up
do you want to do your platform make a
platform that going doesn't make him on
the other side of that coin a couple
months back when that may be the shorter
than that when Greg Miller announced
that he had gotten banned from next
year's even know exactly who's back
exactly that's always right Saab is
right like again we gotta get out of
this whole thing of just because
someone's political views or whatever
religion that different from your old
negate when somebody is wrong know it
out of your feelings that's the deal I
have with this generation in social
meaning game is bro like we don't have
to anything but if something happens to
you because it's like industry as a
whole have his own interests they put a
muzzle on but don't talk to anybody it's
funny and you start looking at different
a boy don't pick on my ticket right now
today ever do like a public like
announcement did pass go hey we did this
we're sorry I gotta take off guys go to
work it's you know like I said the call
when we already thing they're in the
wrong but you know I'll see you guys
next week
keep that bad it's just to me it makes
the whole industry look bad man when
people you need to be seen in a light
where you handle things professionally
and this this industry sometimes is
petty man this is easy to say that this
is your guy no not at all everybody he's
vilified for BS I think and honestly I
when he was with Greg Miller right I
felt that he was the perfect counter to
Greg with him you listen to Greg Miller
Greg Miller talks a mile a minute and
it's just dude going going nuts right
and maybe you like that maybe you don't
colin is a very sort of intelligent like
he he's acquired a dude you know what I
mean like he he's just different
he's just different I thought that was a
perfect mixture for that and that's what
made podcast beyond so little big so
when all this stuff happened my thing is
just like to do everybody deserves the
same treatment the same respect
it's just professionalism and beyond
just how he's being treated
it just makes to me it makes the whole
industry look bad and petty is very
childish who the people you cross
because these people got abilities to
reach back and pull you back off the
line right obviously obviously was in
but she's not my friend relationships
Flixter relationships that's all there's
a thing that I find about packs is that
packs was originally not a gaming thing
it was a board game it was for tabletops
it was for all of those things to the
point where the gaming industry invaded
it and took it over and now packs us to
almost figure that out
hates you have unplugged now ensuing
because you have to have it now even
funnier even funnier is the fact that
packs itself has had issues in the past
with some of its uh its founders having
had it said some statements
statement some racially charged
statements a naked man they do they
didn't get back from their own event but
it's when you know sudden you take a
stance on the soapbox and you're living
in a glass house I feel you all is very
funny for the jokes I am only the best
haha
today they did a Fresh Prince of bel-air
when they took he was in the club I
don't care what nobody say if you don't
get a laugh off for that or for the
strength the comedy level of it it is
he's not harmed in any way he get his
money back right now the people that are
going to the event what if they don't
look back and it came just because your
man is there and now he not there doing
whatever City go do and that's it they
don't if they don't care about packs
they just Kato today like this is this
packs that's coming up that we long to
make sure I wish it was easy so I can
see all of the mopey faces it's not
gonna beat it and I'm a free college
it's sensitivity we are going to move on
oh speaking of shade actually no no but
we good we got kick you're up man yeah
I'll give you my criticism
what is going on man shadow keep that
was good offer
alright so you know since destiny our
Bungie has broken away from the evil
clutches of Activision and it's
obviously parenting not to look like
they were the evil clutches to be honest
with you because all the upgrades and
all the distance in the date they put
with ourselves
Oh to separate yourself from the
practice that was Activision this one
rings truer to me now the DLC the shadow
keep is coming out and we all know was
supposed to release on September 17th
and what Bungie decided to do because
they don't think the DLC wasn't up to
snuff instead of putting out a broken
deal see what they have to go and fix
and hotfix on a Monday or a Tuesday and
take it offline they decided to hold it
back to October 1st and under the old
regime which was Activision I believe
that they would have been forced to keep
their street date and they would have
had no to put it out and have hot fix it
later on a lot of people were turned off
by the old practices where every time
they released the dlc was broken and
they had to fix it they had the nerf
this they had to do that and they didn't
think they destined Bungie took the
proper care with the IP this shows to me
in my opinion them being in control it a
showing you putting the best foot
forward that a will give you the best
product they can possibly can have of
entry but you shout out to the Fonz the
ground in the game they'll kick IOP out
of packs if King does that back to loot
the fuzz for rideability
you know say let me jump in real quick
cuz um obviously we all have our destiny
crew addict is left and uh you know I
saw fields did we got a division man
here let me jump in oh I hit too much
slander miles off I don't know what
Yacht appreciate but
I agree I think this move doesn't happen
if Bungie still tied to Activision
because like September has notoriously
been that strict Disney released cadence
deadlines because they always want to
separate it from call of duty which
means drop in the late October or
November and shout to about this man cuz
I really feel bad I'm still having mic
issues to jakka see but um you know
we're supposed to do this topic on the
last word and um yeah I think that you
know listen let's be real to like
Borderlands was there Monster Hunter is
there in September what gears is there
like I have no problem with them saying
yo this needs a little bit more time to
cook October 1st is right there at the
top of the month that's the benefit and
then you know what's crazy King is that
we're gonna get cross save earlier now
yes so they were initially trying cross
save at the launch would steam you know
stated all that stuff or at the same
time around logic that's a lot to take
on at once with a new launch of an
expansion so now you move that up you
get people prepped for cross save ahead
of time I think that's dope and um yeah
I think I think it's I think it's a good
move this this there's nothing in my
opinion but let's be like what two weeks
it's not even nice major so it's like
look good move I Greek King if this is
activist this cannot happen I think this
is more of Bungie having more control of
their future slash question and that
cross se was being out a little bit
earlier do you think that the rise in PC
players that will extra make a mass
exodus from other consult I don't think
places PlayStation cross so the mass
exodus do they go to the higher platform
with 60 frames per second 4k or I'm
hearing people say specifically them
like you people would say like yo the
only reason why I would never go to PC
is because I'm not usually losing my
character I'm not losing like paragraphs
I'm not losing all as exotics I'm not
losing all that now they're saying you
bringing your character every day to
whatever platform you
play instant win to me that was the
biggest well I didn't even care what day
the expansion could be on one map like I
didn't care what they expand but that is
all as a destiny fan I want it you know
I'm saying because that's the thing no
one wants that guess destiny is so
grindy the investment that you put in
with all that snow to give all that up
and start brand new and I did it it is
it's not pleasant
isn't that less right is it cross-play
also or just crazy just gonna cross
cross on the shirt is something down the
road you know I'm saying but you shot
the Fonz he said that's the biggest
McCain that's listen shot the full of
Fonzie four greats
he's the greatest he would play
playstation three characters just to
play destiny with his boss and not to
put your business out there but you know
I'm saying like just to play with people
that he knew then come play with us on
xbox right just a play like play with us
and do the whole grind over like this -
oh oh Xbox and then did the whisper yeah
Fetty you know what else has crossfade
but also across play four layers three
but we go callable one and done what's
the single-player so to be petty I do we
play but all right let's give it to the
bad destiny foe because we could run
this time we get to the ground real
quick let's get let's hear these
opinions from sahrvin jump in first you
go right ahead P yeah thank you I
actually have good things so number one
Activision for me it's I'm so happy they
broke away
they take the repeat their games and
they put them out half-assed and with
with shadow keep coming out and it being
delayed in Bungie saying hey this isn't
ready I come in people that say hey this
isn't ready we need to clean it up we
don't want to give you half a product
and we saw that happen and I'll a little
shout out to dizzy
Borderlands 3r or in packs three when we
were up there and that thing didn't play
and they were like
but I gave him more the credit for the
playing that game and I said to myself
if he is so behind his people and he's
willing to you know wait make us wait
for this and it we waited I will buy
that game basically because of that
reason and with with the with destiny oh
I I looked at them and then when they
say hey we're pushing this back I like
it I think that's a good thing I think
that's a plus in my book and I think
that's a great decision said this before
but I don't give a rat's ass about this
but I have to say though I I do I am
happy about this
because the fact the matter is that the
fate of destiny rests solely with them
now know finance to help nothing from
the side so you have no influences from
the side no financial help from the side
it's all on you so they've generally
been able to get away with releasing a
brand new product have him having the
base go crazy about stuff like you know
things not working a ridiculous amount
of grind to get up to the new content
stuff like that that if they had had
more time to cook probably wouldn't have
happened if they had been able to make
the call on those things so the fact now
that they're making the call on that and
they know that's what's best for the
game and that the game has to whatever
expansions are coming out have to launch
in a state that's acceptable to the
hardcore that is still supporting the
game you have you know and it's only two
weeks so it's not like it it needed that
much more work but the fact that they
can do that without a hesitation I think
is great for the game you know I I'm all
for studios being able to do what
studios need to do to to put out the
best product possible without influences
from the suits I hate that
so I shout out to destiny I hate you so
I've made some comments recently about
the switch so our good friend Andrew
Wilson CEO he said he's been evaluating
them platform conversations looking at
things and just didn't fix which in the
profile in terms of ecosystem and stuff
so um he made argument that uh most
PlayStation 4 owners and Xbox one owners
and PCs that the games that they have on
EA they don't feel that they would be
wanted on the switch video they already
have their other versions so um yeah
it's got to look a switch community up
in uproar yeah you know it's it's it's a
little wild out here in these trees I
want to bring this to the Lords right
quick you know EA shading the switch and
let's get what's get PD for I'm curious
what P DS view on edge Wilson statement
that uh he just feels that their their
base might not want switch ports so it's
free for switch to have those ports I
think that EA may be looking at it like
hey we can I'm gonna Dave's gonna love
this one I don't think they're gonna be
able to take half of their games and
dumb them down to what switch can
produce so I think that they're trying
to be diplomatic about it and being like
hey I don't think these people are gonna
want to play our games they want to put
the work in to do it yeah and and won't
the two different things
yeah it's so it'll be it'll be really
interesting if they can end up like
being able to a lot of those what what
games do you think are actually people
are gonna want to play on that because
it's well I feel like the switch when
you want to take it out it's gonna be
more of our weight gain and and what
what happened was they have so flaunted
it two versions of FIFA
they were subpar they were it will
feature no content cut like features cut
out
not even like a diminishing graphics or
anything like that they were features
cutout that were in the main game that
would have made the game infinitely
better and they just didn't do they
didn't put the time into it so much to
me
wait I mean FIFA is not selling on on a
port the only way you can play it
portable it would have been a switch mmm
yes that's BS I know I I just I honor
I'm surprised number one that they would
publicly say that like because you don't
know what you could produce you or would
want to produce so why would you just
say in general hey we're not we're not
doing anything for switch that's just it
just doesn't seem logical to me but I I
think that in the end I think they just
play it like oh you know hey I could
bring home any of these girls but I
don't wanna you don't think that don't
say that distract us from his No
mr. Wilson for having the foresight Oh
Mike and why should I be on my graphics
for you knocking bring your specs up I
refuse sir if so buckets really Madden
coming out it ain't coming out on sweet
you know we go ahead to play you like to
play around the big boys you know why
because no they refuse to drop a pixel
down to fit it on a switch I was mr.
Wilson you have integrity sir if he had
integrity would have said just what you
said instead of some thought I told I
agree with you King for once I get where
you're going with this narrative this
power down I get it you're there but
look here's the dip even shout the law
stuff what he gave me a good point
you can't tell me like people don't
realize you don't have to do the latest
games what's going on like match for
match right but you can't tell me that
solve they couldn't do a Mass Effect
trilogy if it's what I'm saying
a dragon's ate like the old backlog
that's all no like you can easily do
that now with sound like hotcakes so
that right there
maintenant is just dumb the fight for
numbers even though it was a
stripped-down version or whatever like
that a full-featured version it was
still crazy you know I mean exactly not
the numbers in it support them like
that's the crazy thing so to me it's
like again I'm looking a bigger picture
we all know how EA feels about their
microtransactions you're the we know
about how you know you want to implement
the mr.
like that and in their defense because
of switches online infrastructure I
don't think it's just not too much work
right to get all that pop in the way
probably they want it to get popular
revenue that's just what it is but as
far as saying that people ain't gonna
want it nah fam I'm not and I like it
robbed and shot the ng we'll see madam
an amazing person
yeah good stop of the day this is a this
is a move the decision that to me I
think it's a mistake MPD supports that a
buddy suggest that Indies and third
parties that the port's have done done
substantially better on switch so this
is one they choose to do they right now
their financials wasn't that great I
mean they had to aid apex kind of is
slow now right now natives and bushes
right let's just call it what it is I
don't know how the Star Wars game and I
love that Star Wars I love what I see
but yeah now's not the time for EA to be
like nah we're not gonna put it over
with the hottest system like that to me
is not financially smart that is my
opinion
yeah that's BS reason cuz I mean you
could say whatever you want about all
the Bethesda ports or whatever you know
the Vaseline yeah that's all true they
wouldn't keep making them if they
weren't selling bro that's it because
unlike some don't care about that bro
like switch owners don't care like yeah
y'all laugh with the Vaseline Edition
5:40 p.m. the world's is gonna be there
as well
oh that's what I'm saying it's gonna be
crazy yeah man it's a stupid reason it's
just he just sounds stupid saying that
because this is a better excuse just
come up with a better excuse you know
how hard they work on those faces over
here [ __ ] face like everybody wandering
around
no matter
that's my Tom Brady with that [ __ ]
anyway that was like beauty anybody got
anything else do i LP polled this week
with the recent signing of ninja away
from twitch to the mixer streaming
platform exclusively what do you think
about this impact of this move for
Microsoft the choices are a huge signing
for the future of Microsoft services and
engagement be mixer stays third place
way to games at OSI I don't care it's a
digit off the bag or vicotry
that is the question those are the
choices please Rock the votes when they
go up Lord PE salute for standing up for
us in the realm we whole problem does
from our bad mic situation until we get
everything right not with Yeti and their
bad drivers but uh but oh yeah I just
want to make a quick announcement for we
do our normal out shows are next week
the Lord's will be away to play we're
gonna play New York City oh yeah we're
gonna be in a lot of PD will be in
attendance as well yeah I'm saying as
far as a little height as well so we're
gonna be out there within a full effect
on showing everybody what's going on in
New York City this new event new
coverage there so we're gonna really try
to do it out for you guys to give you
guys as much coverage as the Lords
possibly can so we'll be reppin next
Saturday so there won't be a show next
week but we'll have a few surprises and
hopefully some exclusive to show you
guys so stay tuned for that and again
the patreon support the super chat
support all this helps us to upgrade our
equipment to do the things that we need
to do to trial to hit these shows for
you guys man none of this stuff is it's
cheap so anything you guys do as much as
we choke and we pander with stuff you
know say but it does help us big time so
let's get these outros proppant lord
pd in the realm what's going on nothing
much same old same old Monday to Friday
on Twitch yes I know I said it
smell though I am there like like like
COD was saying we're gonna be a play on
my see this weekend it's gonna be a lot
of fun King put that thing away
New York is like us I'm from New York as
as I said last time I was here anyone
that wants to be streaming with us hit
me up I know that we have plans on doing
it in multiple streaming services so if
you want to stream on mixer that is
something that we are going to be
looking to do shortly style so don't
feel that I'm saying it's not gonna
happen but it has always been a plan it
is actually something that we've been
discussing for since the beginning of
the year we discussed it with our
streaming meeting in the first of the
year this was a plan that we were gonna
be doing this year but we do need
streamers to be participating you know a
couple hours here and there just just
looking to do it once a day for a couple
hours just to you know show you guys the
love about us and dizzy I don't want to
hear it all we already said it you
already said it
oh my god hilarious all right so just
what once again thank you guys for for
letting me come in for that subject
matter you know how much I you know is
dear to my heart you know the old
streaming subjects so thanks guys
appreciate it fantastic have you in the
room always getting your thought process
on these things the string team lead
Lords now don't will be in the building
Lord soft will be in play New York City
showing its face it's off it's a
pirate's Oscar so ya know the eyes have
returned to have poker no doubt man
they're definitely excited to go out
there to play and why I see you know
this is a small new advantage only
like a couple years old the first time
we're actually going so it should be
cool should be an excellent so if you
you're from NYC come out say what's up
to the Lord's and why pull up for real
like this is our city we want to show
love mandate we don't have a lot of
events it's always LA whatever so we got
acting like the home team to borrow NYC
let's get it yeah so definitely you guys
can catch me on Twitter Lords have IOP
and on be excelling on PSN and xbox live
again big shout-out to all the UH
patreon winners and again thank you for
the support guys every every month we
got one or two new patrons we really
appreciate that man it helps so much and
the fact that that our base keeps
growing and our fans keep growing it
like it's amazing to us so thank you
thank you but man goes to supreme and me
I see you was already know goes in the
building but uh Lord King man and why
see reppin was going on yeah yeah and
down on Adrien Broner go supreme is in a
chat let me see
ok so you know we have played New York
coming up and I think that's gonna be
huge
for a lot of reasons one is like like
Cognito said that's home base securing
the only secure home base first and you
move forward and we're trying to give
you different views on gaming in general
you're gonna get a chance to see an
event that you probably didn't hear of
didn't know about but will know a lot
about by the Lord's cuz we out here
we're covering this stuff just like
sovereign said I do appreciate every
last patreon subscriber I do appreciate
every last person that was watching live
I'm hungry scenes where they're so
beautiful and you guys in this chat
consistently every week I swear like
when I say is a family type of thing I
see a name and I'm like that's my man
so when when Chris hit me up on Twitter
I know exactly who
for heart was it was immediate follow
right back oh oh I keep it real like we
play video games it has nothing to do if
you like place I don't care about a
Lauren stuff that doesn't matter
you know he's never been disrespectful
our chat is one of the best chats that
stick to very respectful very clean and
none of that other stuff we leave that
stuff at the door we know it's about
games all right this week Kos will be up
well give you a great statue
um which bathroom is you know finishing
yoga see back there that stuff is home
efficient and um combat talk won't be
this week but it's coming up soon
because we have shawn porter versus
Aroldis the truth Spence and that's
going to be a knockout drag-out one of
those fights that you decided to watch
oh you called your friends over that you
i'm gonna give you all the equipment
that you need to talk about it so you
can act like you know something you
don't listen i watch that UFC i didn't
know anything but what I did know was
that Kolby Covington is probably the
next electrifying UFC fighter if you if
you hate him you're tuning in if you
love him you tuning in that's not a
person that you're gonna be indifferent
on and I want to watch every fight that
man has so you already know me yeah
check us out um Chuck I said we're gonna
have the audio up later tonight look how
bout so have that going and again so
just to be clear will be no show but
we're gonna have a lot of coverage for
you guys try to get as much coverage as
possible
um launch of gaming that night please
check out for that you know I'm saying
stream team me and PD got some things
planned and hopefully I don't wanna blow
it up too much but a exclusive interview
with some exclusive people but we'll see
we'll see how that pans out but um yeah
much love and the realm like King said
all the support everything is tremendous
man we really could not do this without
you guys
and it's always good to see y'all up in
the chat starting trouble and be petty
it's all those delbet if anybody because
if you enjoy your Sunday and uh we'll
catch you later